well it's day two of kamala harris's
root causes of migration tour in central
america and things
aren't going well she is in mexico today
but still won't be going to the southern
border and harris defending that
decision
in a cringe-worthy interview and then
blowing up over it again
this afternoon do you have any plans
to visit the border at some point you
know
we are going to the border we've been to
the border so this whole
this whole this whole thing about the
border we've been to the border
we've been to the border you haven't
been to the border i
and i haven't been to europe and i mean
i don't know i don't
understand the point that you're making
i'm not discounting the importance of
the border well listen
i've been to the border before i will go
again
but when i'm in guatemala
dealing with root causes i think we
should have a conversation about what's
going on in guatemala
so jesse my new excuse for everything is
but i haven't been to europe
in the last three months right no one's
been to europe we're not allowed to go
to europe
permission to make an analogy katie all
right permission so let's say emma comes
home
and there's bees inside the house
because i left the door open
and she says jesse there's bees in the
house do something and i say
i'll take care of this i'm going to deal
with root causes and then i leave the
house
leave the door wide open wander to the
neighbor's house
and talk to him about his beehive that's
what kamala harris is doing
she's wasting time at the neighbor's
house
talking about a beehive but all we want
her to do is go to the door
and close the door did this happen that
was very busy this is a real story
right the root cause this thing is a
cop-out they're just buying time
if they cared about root causes they go
to wuhan and check out the lab but they
don't
all biden did was basically open the
border then
tell kamala go to guatemala and blame
guatemala
yeah and now she says to lester holt you
know what all the stuff i'm doing here
in guatemala you're not going to see
results for years
well that's great because biden's a
one-termer a republican's going to have
to deal with it
and speaking of lester is he alive she's
out there
making analogies worse than i am
cackling
and he's just sitting there like a mummy
she
you got to watch the whole video too
because she's actually
you can hear the audio of her swallowing
these are easy questions actually you
can actually hear
gulp from the mic that nbc's picking up
and these are softball questions come on
well i wasn't paying as close attention
as
uh jessie was to the gulping apparently
that's going on but
greg i think that she honestly thought
that she was going to get away with
saying
i've been to the border i've been to the
border and that the media would just
accept that
and move on so i'm glad that lester holt
pointed out that actually you haven't
been to the border as vice president
to what jessie said she it's like she
doesn't
it's not that she doesn't expect hard
questions she doesn't even expect
obvious questions i mean she just wants
to laugh over a glass of chablis
and i bet she's a barrel of laughs but
she needs some serious media training
that that when she's nervous
she makes you nervous she's like it's
like watching a drunk play jenga
you don't know what's gonna happen and
it's not it's not like she's hopeless
it's that she's hapless it's like she
doesn't really want to be there
i remind i was talking to dana about
this this reminds me of the
one and only time that i hosted fox and
friends
and it just wasn't my thing i just
couldn't get down the patter
i couldn't get the happy patter and it
was just like it just felt like i was
putting on a suit that didn't fit
i gotta pull that clip she's got it
right now right now the suit she's
wearing doesn't fit
and it's like she's got if she doesn't
care enough because right now it looks
like she doesn't care
like she's just given up and it's like i
haven't been to europe
she's like she's and then she's laughing
like don't you agree with me
it's like so sad but weird at the same
time i
enjoy it so dana you know they can
continue to be asked about this the
white house is getting pressed
on this not just from the vp's office
but from the white house podium what is
the reason why
they wouldn't go to the border or at
least just you know
is it when does it have a liability for
them well i think it's
obviously it already has you already see
that with the results and for example in
mcallen texas just elected a republican
mayor for the first time and
uh i think since carl said since 1977
and hillary clinton won that district by
40 points so um there are changes afoot
and i don't think media training is
going to solve this problem yeah it
might be too late this is not this is
not a media training issue
um don't blame the communicators it is
her problem
right her and if her instincts were not
on the day that he said
i'd like you to go to the border
remember she went got the border
assignment because she laughed
when she was asked if they were going to
go to the border and they're like okay
now we're going to put you in charge of
the border five days later
her office put out a note like actually
let's be clear it's not the border
it's like they want to separate the
border from guatemala
when and actually the root cause is
actually at the border and the
guatemalan president said that
he said as soon as you said you're going
to reunite families and children the
coyotes showed up and said okay well
who wants to go and that's when
everybody started headed out yeah
so if your instinct is not to say thank
you for the assignment sir
i will be leaving on thursday morning
and i will do a fact-finding mission
i'll come back and tell you all about it
that would have solved all of this
instead they didn't call it a crisis and
they just didn't go and deal with the
issue which means that now they have a
big political problem on their hands
we have a policy process he's in the
house dana yeah
everyone is buzzing about things
speaking of
geraldo you know she says that she has
been to the border before that is true
let's take a listen to the former or the
former senator
when she went to the border for the
first time
oh it's a tweet okay so anyway she said
tweet say it loud say clear everyone is
welcome here no band no wall and yet
yesterday she's in guatemala saying
don't come well what has changed she's
been consistent because that's what the
guatemalan president said that she said
that
you're the problem he said to our vice
president you know she has
i really deeply admire her
no i do she's a historic figure she's
very very important
not enough it may not be enough but i
was going my butt
is that she has a kind of a quirky
nature
that when pressed remember in the
presidential primaries
how unpleasant she sometimes comes
across when she's under pressure
and i it cost her the early exit uh when
she was running for president
and i think this trip is a disaster it
is
because you know why go to guatemala
you could pick up the phone to the
mexican president and you can say
you know that trade deal that we have
pending or you you know those factories
on the border right
you want uh you know want those trucks
to come across as
as freely as they do the big semis then
you have to
do what you did with donald trump when
there was the surge of
of of immigrants in 2019 you've got to
play ball you've got to use the forces
at your
uh your command to mitigate this
horrible flow that's coming and the and
and that she really uh has blown it i i
i think she can recover she'll she can
mature in office
but that that's not a winning formula
there's not many democrats who are
looking at this going this is a great
2024 candidate well
that's that i was just going to say that
because wasn't wasn't she supposed
to be yeah she's supposed to be groomed
for the biden was the placeholder
yeah well this is what happens when you
choose your vice president based on
gender and skin color rather than
actual talent and expertise we're seeing
that disaster
state of california she was united
states senator you can't
demean her just because she's well
there's a reason why she got zero votes
and had to drop out of the race before
they even started taking votes so anyway
ahead barack obama hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else